Corporate social responsibility or CSR
for short is the social responsibility
of companies as part of a sustainable
economy
an economy includes individuals
commercial entities and government
involved in the production distribution
exchange and consumption of products and
services in a society
together these activities help a nation
determine the availability and
distribution of scarce resources to meet
the needs of its people
the system also known as the economic
system allocates Land Resources labor
and capital to produce for consumption
in addition decision-making authorities
determine the value of goods and
services within a community the term
usually refers to a country and
describes its resources consumption
inflation economic growth and decline
however it can also describe the
economic structure of a city state local
market or if you look very closely also
a single company
some of these companies have gone
through a long phase of research and
testing of their products investors
needed a lot of staying power and their
business models were exposed to the
violent shocks of the market
in this documentary we will take a
closer look at some of these companies
and their path to success
many of them have had a tough road to
break even
one of the world's oldest airlines
flying the world's longest routes a
brand known across the globe but less
than a decade ago it was hemorrhaging
cash spiraling toward collapse
it's been transformed
[Music]
in 2018 Qantas reported a profit of 1.2
billion US Dollars its largest ever
shareholders were rewarded with shared
BuyBacks and dividends of more than 360
million dollars while employees were
showered with 50 million dollars of
bonuses
that was a far cry from the 2.7 billion
loss announced in 2014. there's no doubt
that today's numbers are confronted
but they represent the year that has
passed and we have now come through the
worst how do you nice to meet you thank
you nice to meet you David glad to be
here welcome to Qantas head office thank
you very much so tell me about that
turnaround what were the main elements
of the turnaround how did that plan
evolve so we had probably the perfect
storm hitting us down
um around 2013. so the conditions I
suppose are important because we had
high oil prices they reached uh well
over four billion dollars the highest
over a hundred dollars a barrel the
highest that we've seen we had
simultaneously a domestic competitor
virgin running errors and trying to take
massive market share and being funded by
a number of foreign Airlines extensively
funded and we also had because of the
very high Aussie dollar a lot of
international carriers flying into
Australia so it was The Perfect Storm on
all of our businesses simultaneously
Joyce announced a two billion cost
cutting program everything from faster
aircraft turnarounds to saving fuel from
optimizing routes the workforce shrank
by 5000 or 15 percent the fleet was
simplified Boeing 747s law retired ahead
of schedule replaced by A3 3200s
an order for eight a380s was deferred
and schedules were changed to maximize
the use of quantities remaining 12a 380s
Qantas dropped unprofitable routes like
Perth to Singapore
on other routes planes would change to
match capacity to demand Joyce himself
took a 36 pay cut
it was one of the most remarkable
aviation turnarounds in history
[Music]
20 Qantas War Market's 100th year
to get a sense of that history I went to
the Qantas Heritage collection at
Sydney's domestic airport it's just near
gate 13 in terminal 3. you can go there
while waiting for a flight so these were
the two Visionaries 1919. who were they
these are the founders of Qantas this is
Hudson fish and this is Paul McGinnis
the airline was born in 1920 founded by
two Veterans of Gallipoli the disastrous
World War one campaign often regarded as
The Crucible of the Australian Nation
Hudson fish and poor McGinnis
established the Queensland and Northern
Territory aerial services to provide Air
transport over the huge distances of
Australia's North
but even then they had International
Ambitions just before World War II
Qantas moved from its headquarters in
Queensland to Sydney and when they
actually moved down from Brisbane to
Sydney in 1938 they packed up the entire
contents aquinas's head office in two
flying boats and flew them down in one
weekend and where was the runway the
runway was actually at Rose Bay which is
on Sydney Harbor so Sydney's First
International Airport is actually not
here at mascot it's actually on Sydney
Harbor
this is Rose Bay where Qantas had its
first International airstrip it's still
used as a terminal and the boat planes
would take off from here on the long
journey to Singapore
the great hulking flying boots would
slowly steadily gutter speed faster and
faster until their 32 meter Wings lifted
them out of the water like huge graceful
water Birds soaring Into the Blue Yonder
during the decades after the war Qantas
established itself as Australia's
Premier carrier
[Music]
bedding itself into the national psyche
by the early 2000s qantas's domestic
rival anset had collapsed and a new
entrant came into the market in the form
of Virgin blue Qantas decided to
establish its own cut price airline
Jetstar and a young Irishman named Alan
Joyce was chosen as CEO
[Music]
foreign
star Joyce managed to create what was
probably the first successful cut price
airline subsidiary of a full-service
parent
it shows a headquarters near Melbourne
far from the Qantas headquarters in
Sydney and proved himself an able
negotiator one of the reasons that the
low-cost subsidiaries never worked
anywhere else in the world apart from
the fact that all the clever
consultancies said they wouldn't was
that there was always massive conflict
in terms of cannibalization
self-cannibalization of the product of
the mainstream carrier and that was
where it required more than just the
ability to set up a low-cost carrier but
also to negotiate all the different
issues of network of pricing and you
know to fight your way through probably
your biggest enemy which was your parent
in many ways success at Jetstar opened
the door to another chief executive role
the Flying Kangaroo itself
but Joyce was soon under attack from all
sides
[Music]
at the dawn of the 21st century the
Flying Kangaroo was an essential link
for Australia and the rest of the world
but as its Century progressed Qantas was
buffeted by International competition
and unrest at home
we have decided to ground the Qantas
International and domestic fleets
immediately
I repeat we are grounding the Qantas
Fleet now there will be no further
Qantas domestic or International
departures anywhere in the world
Alan Joyce was appointed chief executive
of Qantas in 2008 just as the Australian
dollar started to climb attracting
International competition the oil price
started to increase
and some of qantas's dozen or so unions
began industrial action it was a
difficult time obviously after the we
were coming out of the the global
recession
and and all Airlines were doing pretty
badly the airline business of course is
is riddled with unions I think Qantas at
the time had about 15 or 18 of them and
each of them has quite a considerable
amount of power because if you can
easily ground an airline by by
withholding your services which is a
which is a massive impact Joyce took his
own drastic action he closed down the
airline
the reaction was harsh the consequences
reverberated Nationwide the government
overall was concerned about the extreme
action taken by Qantas that had stranded
tens of thousands of passengers far away
from home having the balls to do it was
a
really a massive thing at the time that
sort of Fades into history now but
I think had had he not done that had I
not done that at the time Qantas would
be very much a
pale picture of what it is today go
right back to probably the most
controversial thing of your career which
was the lockout yeah why was it
necessary
well you probably were aware that we had
gone through a dispute for nearly a year
where three Workforce groups uh we were
acting in unison with each other we
started to lose a lot of money because
we were on reliable because there was a
lot of action happening and we started
losing 20 million a week we could have
given into the demands and this was in
2011 and we believe that those demands
would have restricted Qantas to failure
in the future I wouldn't have allowed
Qantas subsequently to do the turnaround
in 2013 and after the lockout the
workplace relations tribunal canceled
industrial action on both sides now the
Unions would have to resolve their
grievances by arbitration
it meant that Qantas could get back to
work
[Music]
in 2012 Qantas signed a partnership with
Emirates allowing it to deliver
passengers to Dubai from where they
could plug into dozens of routes into
Europe it gave Qantas access to all of
the routes Beyond Dubai that that
Emirates operated which was a massive
contrast to what Qantas had they had
basically London I think in Frankfurt at
that stage
just as the Emirates deal was settling
in Virgin Australia launched its brutal
price War
facing these pressures Joyce announced
his transformation program to A Chorus
of public criticism you had people
calling for your resignation there were
television polls no one it seemed was
supporting you except for the board how
did you keep the board on the side as I
remember at that poll I was on a TV
program sunrise and they said I think I
probably forgot the stats now but they
said it just in a poll before I came on
I was announcing the turnaround plan
what we were doing to improve it and he
said 98 during the high 90s of people
want you to to resign and my answer
there was well it's not popularity
contest and if you think doing the CEO
jobs popularity counselor she should be
doing it and I'm here to work for the
board and for the shareholders and
they're fully supported me but how did
you get the support of the staff so we
we we figured that some of the
principles around the transformation
were it just could couldn't be a focus
on financial outcomes it actually had to
have two other things going at the same
time it had to deliver great customer
outcomes and we couldn't take anything
from the customer and I had to engage
our people and probably another
stakeholder because of the iconic brand
that we are was the general public so we
spent a lot of time on managing
communicating and talking to all the
stakeholders to bring them together that
that said though personally how did you
take it I mean did you sleep yeah
actually quite good one of the things I
you know I worked in Aer Lingus and was
my first Aviation job and one of the
things that they trained our management
there and was mindfulness which is a big
thing these days as well and allowing
people to focus and when you got home
you know my partner Shane he wanted to
talk about what was in the Press what
was occurring as you can imagine he was
reading it and I didn't because then I'm
at home I'm going to switch off I'm
going to block that out and that helped
me get through that period but where
does that come from I mean one you must
have a you know extreme sense of
self-belief where does that sense of
self-belief come from so I think my
parents have been always been my role
models so my mother she's only four foot
nine she's an Irish mother as you can
imagine and she's like one of my
brothers calls her the best
pound-for-pound fighter in probably
Dublin because she really has always
stood up for the family
to bullies and she was a determined
individual still is and so you I always
got that sense of purpose from them and
my parents neither my parents finished
secondary education I was actually the
first in the family in our history of
our family The Finnish secondary let
alone tertiary education a lot of people
watching us talk right now are wondering
what lessons they can take away from
what happened during the Qantas
turnaround I would say that you you
develop a plan you get as much diversity
in collaboration together so around our
senior leadership table I've got four
females the other three gay men so we
got a very diverse group but I think
it's diversity of thinking in all many
different forms and I think well we're
very passionate about all forms of
diversity you know we're one of the
leaders on on the marriage equality the
debate here in Australia and giving the
amount of lgbti customers we have
um employees that we have and
shareholders that we have we thought was
a very important campaign for us to take
here to announce
Joyce's outspoken support for same-sex
marriage earned him an embarrassing
encounter in Perth
an anti-gay marriage activist pushed a
pie into his face so at the time it was
a bit of a surprise because I didn't
know what it was for and and I think
Jeffrey Thomas who was the journalist
interviewed me on the stage I think he
figured it out before I did and asked me
that question you'd think it was because
of your support for marriage equality
and it was a very angry forceful pie to
the face it was very much a message of
that I want you to stop talking about a
you're a powerful gay man and I'm
threatened by your commentary and your
insistence on it
foreign
with Qantas back on a firmer Financial
footing Joyce is looking to the Future
and that's Ultra Long Haul by 2022 the
airline plans groundbreaking flights
from Sydney and Melbourne to London and
New York
the routes are only possible because of
a wave of innovation in aircraft design
this technology changes the game the
pert London servers that we've Now
operate for a year has been the best new
service in our 99-year history the best
customer ratings the best financial
performance we haven't made money on the
London market for 10 years since the
global financial crisis it made money
from day one we're getting 94 C factors
we're getting a premium people willing
to play more to fly direct and we know
if it works on Perth it will work on
Melbourne and Sydney to London and
Melbourne and Sydney to New York to
Chicago to Rio to Cape Town
[Music]
Captain slate how do you do David Queen
from Bloomberg
take a seat
[Music]
to make the turnaround work Joyce had to
have the buy-in from all parts of the
organization
Pilots now have to think about more than
just flying planes
flight management was like a really key
part of the turnaround tell us exactly
how that affected the the the the flight
management and and actually the partners
um with regards to aircraft utilization
so we have some of the highest
utilization of any airlines in the world
at the moment the A330 that we're
sitting on at the moment they utilize up
to 18 hours a day so our networks team
have finally tuned our program so that
the aircraft are flying and it's a fine
balance between having them on the
ground for the required maintenance and
utilizing them and increasing our
Revenue we also did a big piece of work
on our 35-minute turnaround so to reduce
the turnaround of our domestic aircraft
we introduced dual door boarding and
disembarkation and we had a whole team
of Frontline people involved in the
workshopping around how we could do it
so obviously the juggling of cleaning
stuff catering engineering Etc so we've
got a very precise precision timing
schedule to ensure that happens within
35 minutes I find it really interesting
that you as a pilot of talking about
revenue and revenue targets and such
something new since you've been what 30
years I believe as a pilot with Qantas
who would I know
now we know we're in really challenging
environments um so fuel efficiency so
we've introduced a whole lot of fuel
efficiency measures with regards to
running our auxiliary power units on the
ground we've implemented single engine
tax in to save you know a few kilos here
and there but across the year across the
fleet it all adds up so fuel saving is
very much so this is our Central
operations area for Corner Qantas is
ultra Long Haul program means that
optimizing routes is essential Captain
Alan Dickinson is the guy in charge of
developing the new flight planning
system we had a flight from Sydney to
Santiago which was probably a really
good example in that we could see just
by dipping down a little further south
than than normal it was able to pick up
a jet stream and then by just dipping
down a little bit further south and then
coming north a little bit sooner than
the old system would was was planning we
were able to save a 10 the fuel on that
flight but when you look at this system
compared with the old Capricorn system
what sort of percentage savings are we
looking at so we will Target we're
hoping to achieve around the one percent
saving fuel saving
we are still this is a very new system
we're still in the process of
introducing the new system but we have
high levels of confidence that over the
you know the short term we will be able
to achieve around about a one percent
savings I mean given the fuel prices one
percent is a lot of money and every
every cent counts as we say every killer
while looking for savings safety remains
a priority
sahanger and Sydney were the enormous
A380 comes for Servicing
so tall they had to raise the roof it's
so wide they had to widen the space
Jackie Scott has been a Qantas engineer
for 10 years safety before schedule
that's the Qantas motto well Airbus
actually dictates when most of our
components are changed so they may
decide that a particular Park needs
changing at one thousand hours watches
will say 750 hours so we have a quarter
of that time
spare so if any unforeseen circumstances
we have a little bit extra time as well
as we just want to be as safe as
possible not leave things to the last
minute if Joyce is going to make his
Ultra Long Haul program work he's going
to have to make sure his passengers want
to take the flights and one way to
entice them is the food this is our
little Test Kitchen right we do a few
events from here but mainly we do all
the testing for the menu
Qantas has got Top Chef Neil Perry
working with Scientists on menus to
enhance sleep in hydration for Ultra
long-haul flights here we have Danae who
looks after hello our cocktails which
have alcohol in them of course but also
our mocktail which is knocking out for
us now because the whole rehydration of
our passengers is a major Focus for us
especially on these Ultra long-haul
flights especially on the long-haul
flights thank you and you know it really
is all about
not tricking people but getting them to
drink as much delicious rehydration as
they can through we do a great infused
teas we do coconut water
[Music]
Harry and his chefs are constantly
working on creating food that is still
delicious at high altitudes we look at
that in relation to the Long Haul we try
to dial the spices and the chili down a
little bit stimulating spices are not
great when you're trying to relax the
whole idea is that we get proteins
starches beautiful leafy green
vegetables legumes those sorts of things
help really stimulate the sleep
foreign
gears up toward beginning the longest
flights in its history Joyce needs to
remain Vigilant about the risks that
could once again buff at the airline
Qantas is not Invincible I think what we
saw in 2012 to 2014 really shows that it
was a near-death experience and what
Qantas faced at that point was a war on
two fronts it can lose money
internationally as long as it's making a
lot of money domestically but if both
divisions are facing pressure and losing
money then it's a really difficult
situation for Qantas and it can happen
again Joyce has pledged to stay on as
CEO until 2022 when the direct flights
to London and New York begin
the potential risks to the airline will
remain at the Forefront of his mind
we've been around for 99 years we're the
oldest continuous operating airline in
the world and we've always reinvented
ourselves at the disrupted ourselves
before somebody else's hands and I think
we're always on edge we're always
thinking where could the next disruption
come from what do we need need to do to
stay ahead of that game and we're very
much always concentrating on that
thank you
foreign
[Music]
it's among the most profitable car
makers in the world yet in 2013 this
French car maker was facing bankruptcy
since then its new chief executive has
achieved a remarkable turnaround and
then done it again across the border in
Germany
I met the man who was one of Europe's
most influential car Executives at his
Paris headquarters five years ago you
were facing a near-death experience so
we need to keep on being agile we
understand how important it is to move
around the roadblocks and the more
chaotic the world around us is the more
agility is an asset for a company like
ours
[Music]
PSA owns the Brand's Peugeot Citroen DS
automobile Opel and voxel
in 2018 the combined group reported
record earnings and its audio unit made
a return on sales of 7.6 rivaling its
German peers
profit was driven by sales of the
European car of the year the Peugeot
3008 SUV
the record result was also helped by
Opel Vauxhall which PSA bought from
General Motors in 2017 and turned around
after two decades of losses PSA was
really on its knees they lost 8 billion
dollars over two years most industry
observers had counted them out they were
too slow and then Carlos Tavares came in
and in the matter of a few years took
out a lot of cost improved efficiency
improved asset structure
tavares's turnaround formula was called
back in the race
cut the number of models in each brand
make more profit on each reduce the
numbers of platforms they're made on and
cut costs everywhere
he was capable to
convince all the people that the number
of models they used to have in the group
was not fitting with the market
requirements and so reducing the the
manufacturing complexity was about to
revamp the product lineup and it was
very hard consider them to do that
because obviously it's affecting the
organization around the plants and
obviously the reducing the cost was a
bit painful
key was the repositioning of brands that
had been confusing customers
DS on top
Peugeot in the middle and Citroen the
value proposition
we want to focus the Creative Energy of
the company on a more limited number of
products completely aligned with the
expectations of the markets in which we
operate the transformation can be seen
in the share price reaching a low at the
end of 2012 at the depths of the crisis
since tavares's appointment was
announced at the end of 2013 the shares
have more than doubled
PSA has been transforming itself for
years I visited peugeot's birthplace at
Social in the Eastern France where the
vast plant is being modernized
the Peugeot Brothers started a rolling
steel mill in 1810 making sauce coffee
pepper and salt grinders even cages for
crinoline dresses
so one of the things they branched out
into was to make penny farthing bicycles
but they were also making carriages and
carts that needed horses and then the
idea came up to the brothers Peugeot
what if we put an engine in front of our
Carriage
[Music]
fast forward to the second half of the
20th century and Peugeot was one of the
most prestigious industrial jewels in a
resplendent France making cards for a
growing middle class
[Music]
in the 1970s it bought Citroen which was
struggling and PSA Peugeot Citroen was
born
by the time the global financial crisis
hit in 2008 the company had become
unwieldy producing too many models on
too many platforms with brands that
confused consumers between July 2007 and
the end of 2008 the share price dropped
more than 80 percent the company was
burning through billions
Peugeot needed outside help
by 2013 torque started for the French
State and China's dongfeng motor to buy
14 each for the family to halve its
Holdings and Carlos Tavares was
appointed
Harris started his career in 1981 as a
test driver at Renault
by 2011 he was renault's Chief Operating
Officer second only to Carlos gone
then came the Bloomberg interview in
which Tavares laid out his personal
Ambitions it was really surprising
actually because here you have somebody
who is the right hand man for Renault
Nissan which was a very successful
company at the time didn't have any of
the problems that you see today
essentially saying I'd really like to
become a CEO and if I have to leave my
current company to do it I will
he didn't last much longer at Renault
after that no matter by the end of 2013
he was appointed to the top job at
Peugeot a month after assuming the CEO
position Tavares announced his
turnaround plan back in the race
he's a ruthless Cost Cutter and he's had
to be and that's why Peugeot has margins
at a similar level to the likes of BMW
over the past year although some of that
is to do with restruction charges and
just experience you know he's been in
the industry a long time
follow me
in his five years at the helm Carlos
Tavares has managed to return not just
Peugeot Citroen to profitability but the
German car maker Opel as well
[Music]
the interesting thing is that we've got
French cars coming off the production
line and German cars coming off the same
production line the Peugeot 3008 and
opel's grandland X
two quite distinct cars when Tavares
first visited social his message was
clear
the first time that Mr Tavares came we
were in the body shop he sees the body
shop manager and he asks what is your
added value what is the return on
investments of this workshop and the
manager stood there completely stupefied
because that wasn't something we were
used to working with
today that has completely changed we
have changed the culture because
effectively today from the manager to
the operator we think about the cost
price we know that we have to be
competitive with countries where prices
are lower it was not very sophisticated
it was quite simplistic to a certain
extent you see people when I came to the
PSA group in December 2013 were working
like hell they were working 12 hours a
day eventually more and the more they
work the more the results were read
so we started from a very simple
recognition which was that if we are in
trouble it's not because we are not
working enough
we are working like hell
one of the early challenges was to bring
France's unions into the fold it's very
difficult in Europe to take people out
of the workforce and you've got to
remember that Peugeot took quite a hefty
subsidy during the financial crisis to
save the company they had a three
billion rights issue as well but they
were very close to going bankrupt so I
think the unions accepted that they had
to cut costs and it's done been done
through natural attrition as well but
you know he's certainly taking people
and a lot of costs out the business
was capable to build up an aliens with
the poor reform trade unions and just
after a couple of years it was it's
crazy because all the political driven
trade unions are reduced to silence
because for instance recently everyone
was granting a significant bonus in the
firm and so it's not possible for these
trade unions to uh to speak anymore but
would the unions become more difficult
as PSA group becomes more profitable
with the five unions I have in my
company representing 80 percent
of my people they have signed all the
Strategic plans all the performance
plans and they have been one of the big
supporters of this profitability
Improvement that we have delivered over
the five years I think they understand
that this is a this is a race you see uh
it is it is a competitive game that we
are uh facing every day I asked this
question to my unions um in December
2018 and I told them look guys we are we
are profitable our situation is very
good I can hear here or there some
tensions and some small issues I don't
want those issues to grow and I ask my
unions should I ease a little bit on the
accelerator pedal the back in the race
targets were met two years early
heralding the next stage of tavares's
plan back in the race and its
operational excellence outcome is the
foundation
on which we are going to put the
Strategic profitable growth plan that we
have called push to class while back in
the race was about restructuring and
weeding out underperforming models
pushed to pass shifted the focus to
expansion as Tavares pushed to compete
with bigger rivals
thank you
PSA gets about 80 percent of its revenue
from the European market where
automakers face a consumer slowdown and
EU emissions regulations are
accelerating the adoption of electric
cars
sales in China are also a problem
Sinking by a third last year making the
car maker even more reliant on the
wobbly European market that explains its
goal to increase sales outside Europe by
50 percent by 2021. the first one will
bring the Peugeot brand to the US and a
Canadian Market second one will bring
Citron to the Indian market and third
one will bring the opal Bank to the
Russian Market those are the three big
announcements on which we are putting
our energy and our Focus to get there
Tavares expects his staff to go the
extra mile
this is this concept of the extra mile
that you talk about
where if one person fails because
everyone's doing the extra mile if you
manage the team only on the fact that we
cannot fail
and we have a very ambitious goal then
you are just adding tension stress in
the organization
and you are not giving anybody the
possibility to fail because if somebody
fails and the team loses as a result of
an individual failure then that that
person will be in trouble
which means that if you want to keep the
possibility for each of your team
members to fail
and at the same time
the team needs to win
means each team member needs to go one
extra mile beyond the is owned objective
to cover the risk that among one of
those team members there will be one
that can fail and that's very normal
because he's a human being you spoke to
Bloomberg in 2013 and you were talking
about how you would like you were at
Renault still okay and you were talking
about how you'd like to be the leader of
maybe Ford or General Motors so you've
been thinking about being material for a
chief executive for quite some time
where does your self-belief come from
possibly from the fact that since I was
a teenager I was immediately passionate
about cars and and then I became a
mechanical engineer start working for a
car maker at that point in time it was
renewed and went to Nissan overseas
Japan the United States and I I love
this industry it's such a highly
competitive industry because there are
many many contradictory things it's a
capital intensive uh profitability is
not very high the number one guy in the
industry is making 10 profitability
which is not such a big number now there
was an interview in uh lizek a French
newspaper and my office is abuzz with
one part of the interview the fact that
you're at home at seven o'clock every
night having dinner with your wife is
that true every every night when I'm
working here yes and that's the reason
why you have so much time pressure on
this interview all right because yes
because you've got to get home by seven
o'clock yeah are you trying to show a
new example for France
I'm trying to show you that we are here
to get results
not to make ours
and that's very very important you know
it happens to me
to tell some of my top executives
that they are working too much
it happened I said to one of them say
hey I'm worried
you seem tired you travel too much and
you're working days out too long and
that's not good I want you to keep some
bandwidth where you can step back the
acquisition of Opel gave PSA group a lot
of heft when it comes to scale but is it
enough to fund the autonomous vehicle
development as well as to accelerate the
switch to Electric by the end of this
year for example PSA has pledged that
each model developed by its Brands will
have an electric or hybrid version you
have to be very agile if not even
darwinian which means if you don't
change you disappear
[Music]
Opel is the latest automaker to benefit
from the Carlos Tavares turnaround touch
PSA bought the germany-based company
from General Motors alongside UK brand
Vauxhall in 2017.
his task now is to further integrate the
companies to save more money while
driving vital Investments for the future
you need scale there's huge Investments
that have been undertaken by the car
makers at the moment and one thing that
Peugeot didn't have before Opel was
significant scale so the addition of
Opel gives them Scout they're now at
close to 4 million units and that allows
these additional costs for new
technologies to be divided over a wider
product base
Opel lost nearly 20 billion dollars over
two decades
after a year of Tavares at the helm it
reported profit of nearly a billion
dollars in 2018. one horsepower and
basically the first car of open Tavares
tapped Michael Lo scheller Chief
Financial Officer at opal to head up the
division
Tavares he says change the way Opel
thought about making cars just as he'd
done at Peugeot Citroen the key point
from my perspective was a new mindset a
mindset really focused on performance
and implementing things and then he also
gave us a lot of freedom for the
important things of the business in
particular design and the positioning of
our Brand's Opel and voxel
[Music]
the big challenge at Opel was how to
make low margin cars in a high-cost
country profitably low sheller got
unions to agree to eliminate nearly 4
000 jobs through buyouts
then there was a drive to reduce
manufacturing complexity one of our car
lines had 27 different steering wheels
but customers were not asking for 27
different steering wheels so we brought
this down to eight and that is one
tangible example and we have many many
more where actually we reduce complexity
without jeopardizing our customer offer
because obviously the customer is in the
focus of everything we do
to get a better idea of what a German
car should be I met with the design
director who showed me the Opel GTX
experimental concept car
[Music]
if you're a German brand and German
procession is certainly something which
is ingrained in German engineering and
also in a certain kind and German design
and that also is something which helps
us to separate the brands within the PSA
group with the three French ones and
then the British one and the German one
into two different directions which is
great and you can see it at the car I
believe so tell me what I should be
looking at when I'm looking at the the
German Precision over here well very
clearly I think this very proud this
this bold face we call it the visor
which is encompassing all the technical
elements and actually what we call it
it's a techno Hub all the high-tech
elements like radar Lida all these
elements are kind of inside of the visor
and notice we don't have any door
handles since this is a show car yeah a
concept car what we do is we open up the
whole site and we'll see it in a second
once we open it so the whole side of the
vehicle opens up
foreign
[Music]
despite initial success at Opel PSA
faces formidable headwinds
question is still about scale and how to
fund the huge Investments needed to
develop electric vehicles self-driving
cars and Mobility Services
he's been successful with his SUVs over
the last couple of years this is the
fastest growing segment going forward
the fastest growing segment will be
electric vehicles and because Tavares
cut back significantly on R D and capex
over the past four or five years which
has boosted his free cash flow will he
have the technical ability to compete
with its peers as opposed to just
competing on price because their cars
aren't as technically Advanced as as the
likes of the competition so once again
when it looks to coming to making deals
and alliances then for to virus that
would make sense if they went to someone
who already had some sort of pretty
significant Electric Car Technology
that's correct and if you look at the
German manufacturers since the financial
crisis they've made great success of
their sales in China they turn around in
Europe as well and that's allowed them
to build their balance sheets and they
have very strong cash within their
balance sheets and that's allowed them
to invest heavily in electric vehicles
and autonomous vehicles over the past
two or three years that hasn't
necessarily been the case for Peugeot
because it's had to you know cut back in
these areas to bring its cash flow back
up to where we would expect for a
European car company just this year PSA
is said to have been in talks with Fiat
Chrysler and jaguar Land Rover being
bigger may not help the maneuverability
of the company you have to be very agile
if not even darwinian which means if you
don't change you disappear so in that
direction you don't want to be bigger
you want to be very compact very agile
very darwinian on the other side if you
have a significant change in the
regulations that imposes on you very
significant Investments which are going
of course to be a burden for your for
your midterm plan and for your
profitability which is exactly what we
have here that may be one of the reasons
why you would like to share this burden
with other companies and have a volume
scale effect and sharing the burden of
those r d uh Investments that may be a
reason on the other side this is uh our
attitude we are as you mentioned we are
too small to have the Leisure of not
considering opportunities I think that
would be counterproductive so yes we are
open but we are not targeting any
specific company or entity just because
we have a strong balance sheet we are
highly profitable we have the technology
to face electrification we are
developing our autonomous technology so
why should we look for that as a simple
goal it is not a goal it is an
opportunity if it comes on the table
in the past five years Tavares with the
turnaround at Peugeot and opal has
resurrected two struggling car makers he
now finds himself at the center of a
rapidly changing Auto landscape as the
biggest players taught mergers and
alliances it's an arena he clearly
relishes and this is why I think the
pure we are living from now up to 2030
is going to be absolutely exciting and
despite the chaos I'm very very excited
I think this this pressure we have these
disruptions we have are going to create
breakdowns in the history industry and
that means that opportunities will be
will be there on the table
thank you
[Music]
astrazeneca's research facility in
Sweden
walls here are being torn down to
promote conversation between scientists
that could lead to Medical breakthroughs
it's also a message at the heart of a
stunning new headquarters taking shape
in Cambridge when AstraZeneca was
searching for a new chief executive in
2011 it was poised to lose 17 billion
dollars in sales due to expiring patents
Pascal sorio was appointed in 2012 his
task replenish the drugs pipeline since
his appointment the share price has
doubled the problem was that we had
spent a lot of time doing rounds and
rounds of cost cutting reorganization
and doing Shelby bikes as opposed to
doing what what it was we should be
doing as an industry which was really
focusing on science and developing
medicines on day one sorio suspended the
BuyBacks sorio comes for more from an
operational and r d background and I
think that the new people that were put
in charge were also the types of people
who were more focused on on Innovation
than than just sales and driving so
about the science absolutely which is
what Pharmaceuticals about sorio
increased spending on research and
development
focused on cancer the fastest growing
space in Pharmaceuticals and emboldened
scientists to abandon unsuccessful
research you really have to make sure
you choose projects that will succeed
but it's almost as important to choose
the projects that you should not move
into phase three because if otherwise
you spend a lot of money going nowhere
Astra Senior Care was in a situation
where they had been losing revenue for
years and years and really through a
focus back on science back on R D they
were able to launch a number of products
and the oncology business unit really
started growing and for the first time
in 2018 we saw AstraZeneca having the
energy having the spirit and showing the
growth numbers again and really
delivering on the r d pipeline if there
was a single thing sorio did to
demonstrate his tenure would be a new
dawn it was his championing of limpaza
an ovarian cancer treatment the previous
management had scrapped it's now on its
way to becoming a blockbuster the
moniker given to a billion dollar seller
limpaza sparked sorio's curiosity even
before he joined the company I talked to
kiopian leaders and I was really
intrigued because I thought this drug
looks interesting but they're not doing
much with it and in fact they have they
had announced a write-off they had
decided to stop the program and they had
written off the intangible the Goodwill
that was associated with this product
project
and I still remember I went to an
European leader an expert in the field
and I remember having this breakfast
meeting with him in the US and he looked
at me at some stage and he said look
what you're doing is almost criminal
because these drugs would already be
treating patients
so I arrived with a clear view that it
was one of the medicines I needed to
look at and in what I found is a
research team that was really convinced
this was a great drug and had been
trying to convince the organization as
old but had not been successful
in 2017 U.S drug maker Merck agreed to
pay as much as 8.5 billion dollars to
share in the development of limpaza
which can also be used for pancreatic
and other cancers the drugs expected to
generate 2.5 billion dollars in Revenue
this year and next and along with other
key treatments like tigriso and infinzi
fuel the gains expected by analysts
through 2020. he has a nose for a drug
when we show them the data for limpaza
when returning the data for to grisso he
realized that these things could be
medicines and he helped us pull those
things through the pipeline into late
stage development and ultimately to
launch into patients that takes courage
but it also helps us accelerate and push
things faster that was tremendous you
know so things that were originally
blocked were now unblocked and were
moving really fast through the pipeline
[Music]
AstraZeneca was formed in 1999 by the
merger of Sweden's Astra and Seneca of
the UK it's based in the British
University Town of Cambridge where it's
surrounded by some of the most renowned
biopharmaceutical researchers in the
world in our industry it's fundamental
there's nobody who wakes up one morning
saying okay I've got the solution to
develop discovering a new products the
work we do or requires people to work
together you need the scientists to
understand what the future profile is
going to look like what the potential
competitive angle is and what the
potential way of marketing it would be
and what the Physicians would say that's
a very long list of things to have to
deal with when you're dealing with a
program that needs to take 10 years to
come to Market having everyone together
and making sure that they're able to
talk to each other is a key driver many
pangolos showed me around the new campus
and explained how the building is all
about collaboration we're really pleased
ourselves in the middle in the heart of
one of the best life sciences clusters
in the UK and actually probably in the
world the idea behind this building is
it's meant to be transparent porous
collaborative inviting to our partners
the people are interested in the science
that we're doing so that we really make
our science and our scientists
accessible and that's all part of our
cultural transformation inside this
construction there are these huge
Laboratories embedded into the building
there's going to be 19
000 square meters of them that's three
football pitchers all the way along here
there's going to be the deaths where the
scientists will write up their
experiment and then of course all the
support staff I'm told they can't wait
to move in
but first fighting off Pfizer at the end
of the first day the bankers must have
felt a bit sorry for me they came and
they told me you know yeah we have to
tell you you have less than 10 chance of
remaining independent
[Music]
as a work on boosting astrazeneca's
drugs pipeline started to take off a
fresh threat appeared
Pfizer it'd be one of the biggest deals
in all of Pharma history we know that
Pfizer had made an approach in January
we've got a keen buyer a very keen buyer
but perhaps not such a cane seller in
this trade in 2014 astra's U.S rival
made four attempts to buy it in less
than six months the final offer was for
117 billion dollars it would have been
the biggest Pharmaceuticals take over
ever it was a really an interesting day
because I arrived in London and opened
my phone and my daughter had sent me a
message telling me my mom my wife was at
the hospital it was a pulmonary embolism
so I called her and she was fine but it
was a bit of a bit of a stressful day
and then we arrived at the office and we
started working the whole day with the
lawyers as you can imagine bankers
lawyers and our own people and at the
end of the first day the bankers must
have felt a bit sorry for me they came
and they told me you know yeah we have
to tell you you have less than 10
percent chance of remaining independent
so that was at the end of that day I
thought wow that was that was an
interesting well you didn't believe them
clearly
well actually sometimes you know when
people tell me a project has a low
probability of success and I believe in
it I tell them you know 20 is not bad
actually because I only had 10 percent
of uh chance of remaining independent as
fisa continued to chase to create the
world's largest drug maker by sales
lawmakers in Britain Sweden and the US
grew increasingly critical the most
important intervention we can make is to
back British jobs bring British Science
British r d British medicines and
British technology and that is why I
asked the cabinet secretary and my
ministers to engage with both companies
right from the start of this process
AstraZeneca rejected the deal
disappointing many investors this price
doesn't reflect the newest housing a car
in the last 18 months we've made
enormous progress for building our
Pipeline and we believe this pipeline is
going to deliver value
for patients of course but also for
shareholders you had the board on the
side but your investors many investors
say no it was the wrong thing to do
but I also understand that you managed
to use this situation as a way of
galvanizing the staff what happened
there yeah I think it uh it was of
course a stressful time for a stressful
time yes forever but in the company but
it was also a great time uh in
retrospect because it was a time when we
had this Burning platform of showing
that we could actually deliver value not
only to patients but also to our
shareholders we're just focusing on what
we were doing and it really galvanized
everybody to actually uh you know do
their best and that meant showcasing
that astrazeneca's future was bright
Soria projected a 75 increase in annual
revenue by 2023
and announced the company had 15 drugs
nearly ready to go almost double from
the year before he promised to invest as
their shares would rise beyond the 55
pound offer price it took four years to
get there our job was to turn science
into medicine and ultimate get those
medicines to patients you looked at our
success rates from 2005 to 2010 our
success rate from drugs entering
clinical development first and human
experiments to launch were around four
percent today in the most recent
assessment we've done which was looking
at 2012 to 2016 our success rate has now
gone up to 20 we were very good at
focusing on large numbers of projects
but that actually had a relatively low
probability of being medicines today we
very much focused on the quality we
actually cut almost half of the projects
in the pipeline and even with that cut
we still improved our success rate
significantly so that was quality not
quantities hugely hugely important it's
important to remain Nimble and and fast
taste but in order to do that and make
decisions you yourself as a leader have
to have a fair quantity of self-belief
where does that come from
well it's actually uh more than set of
benefits about belief in the people you
have around you believe in the advice
you get belief in in the culture you've
created and it's really about digging in
the data understanding what Physicians
think experts think and you know
aggregating all of this and analyzing it
and at the end of the day it's about the
belief of that you have to take risks
and then and then at some point you have
to accept you maybe if you may fail what
is it that you bring to the organization
that allows that
um that that communication to come out
and and for these drugs to be recognized
when it wasn't before one of the most
important time points is when you you
are in the phase one phase two and you
have to decide whether our drugs should
be developed in phase three and here you
really have to look at it from all
angles and really understand where it
could help patients and how it could be
used in clinical practice and and the
way you do this is really by bringing
people together there and uh and and
really you know brainstorming and
debating And discussing the data and the
various opinions but also beyond that I
think you need to create the right kind
of culture one of the issues we had was
you know we had exp experience a few
setbacks in development we had three
products that failed in that stage
development in 2008 or something like
that and that happens all the companies
have experienced that but at the time
the management company decided okay well
we're not going to fail again
and so you know when you tell people
we're not going to fail you never fail
in phase three because you never move
anything in first grade you've got to
really create an environment where
people feel comfortable taking some
educated risks
so it really is about
sharing knowledge sharing data debating
and being willing to take educated risks
we have entered into an agreement
a global joint level commercialization
with AstraZeneca sorio's most
significant educated risk so far was the
6.9 billion dollar deal in March with
Japan's daiichi sankyo to develop a
breast cancer treatment that could even
replace chemotherapy potentially
reshaping the future of Cancer Care the
potential is very large
uh and we see it as a mega Blockbuster
AstraZeneca was obliged to partly fund
it with a 3.5 billion dollar share sale
highlighting the company's scarce cash
resources they needed to raise money
from the market and they raised a little
bit more because they have some debt
repayments coming up that I think
highlighted the cash flow needs of
course they could have gone and probably
given up some other rating and raised
debt again but that would have been
expensive people would say Equity is
expensive but at the end of the day this
was a much faster way of getting what
they needed and they did it but that's
if there's a focus on cash flow
each deal why is that a key deal for
AstraZeneca I think people today don't
really understand fully the potential of
this medicine it can transform breast
cancer treatment and I personally
believe it can be a very big product and
I don't think people have totally
realized how big it can be
the emphasis on bringing people together
is a key plank of sorio's turnaround
the investment into buildings like this
in Cambridge
and these in Sweden is all about getting
people to come together and share ideas
company was operating in silos
and uh
and actually not necessarily believing
in each other so you had a commercial
function and then you had a r d function
and and and there was not a lot of
belief uh say in commercial that r d was
delivering and in r d we had also
fragmented teams we had the mid immune
team we had you know very different many
different teams not working really
together
foreign
[Music]
site there is a huge model that shows
how existing and new buildings are going
to work together
most of the world's Brilliant Minds do
not work for Astra sanica we have 64 000
fantastic employees but most great ideas
are conceived somewhere else and if we
are going to take part of that we are
going to have to work completely
different with the external World jerkom
Raichel is one of those charged with
making the changes all right this is
clearly one of the modern new facilities
for research and development why does
this work more productively for
AstraZeneca as you can see it's a much
more open environment we have Torn Down
the Walls and we have scientists from
different disciplines working in this
environment which makes it easier for
collaboration why is it make it easier
are they working on the same disciplines
they're working on different diseases we
have scientists that they're researching
heart disease kidney disease and
respiratory disease and the interesting
thing is that those diseases have some
commonalities which now we can actually
understand better by having those
scientists working together at the same
space listen to before all of these
people would have been working
separately on their own disciplines they
would have been working in separate Labs
absolutely
another Innovation is the bioventure Hub
where companies are invited to establish
themselves inside the campus and given
the same access as the rest of the staff
what it means in practice as I said is
the talented people with new
technologies and new ideas will get
inside us a Seneca build their companies
build their develop their science and
they will do that together with us a
Seneca formally informally this has a
completely different company so as an
example we today have our bioventure Hub
here at the company it's 34 external
companies same pass card as I have
access to our full site we share
knowledge
about 18 years ago when I joined
astrazenka we almost pulled down the
curtains before open a drawer that
that's a major major change that with
angered Petrina agabok the chief
executive of AstraZeneca Sweden says the
coffee Lab at the Gothenburg campus is
but one example of how the dynamic is
changing inside the company I think the
biggest thing is the cultural change in
how we operate in terms of opening up
working a lot more with the smaller
companies Academia and you know just
around the world collaborating more
externally not assuming we have the best
people every day inside but rather
opening up is one big thing
I also think actually the cultural thing
sometimes we forget that it's
he has been driving a very very values
driven way of working I think if you
walk around here or anywhere in
Australia everyone would know our five
values and it actually really means
something to people
so you know we put patients first we
follow the science we're entrepreneurial
we play to win and we do the right thing
sorio continues to make changes to gain
an edge in January he reorganized r d
into two divisions one to focus on
cancer the fastest growing and most
lucrative part of the industry and the
other to oversee the rest it wasn't
necessary because of the structure we
had in place served us very well for
about five years or so five years ago we
didn't have much in our pipeline we had
to create this uh early units that were
kind of a biotech units coming up with
new products but as we were becoming
more successful with the full pipeline
the structure was playing against us a
little bit we were becoming a bit too
bureaucratic and too focused on
governance and our oncology pipeline in
particular has grown tremendously and
oncology is a little bit different from
the rest of pharmaceuticals so I decided
that the reorganization was necessary so
we could move very quickly from research
to early development to lead development
in oncology bring people together from
research to development to commercial in
oncology but also in BIO Pharmaceuticals
and when it's to building new markets
AstraZeneca like many is looking to
China and it's increasingly affluent
patients
when did you first begin to see China as
a key Market
uh almost immediately because you know
the as I started I really had to look
for
areas where we could grow you know I had
to look for the strengths of the company
and and number one where we could
rebuild the pipeline how we could
rebuild the power plant but also
looking at this massive patterned expiry
that we were facing where could I find
growth and China was one of those and in
fact the pipeline of the portfolio of
products we had and still have really
addresses the needs of patients in China
so immediately I thought you know we
have to invest in China and keep going
since becoming astrazeneca's CEO sario
has refocused the company on science
he's reconfigured buildings to open them
to outside minds and ideas and he's
replenished the company's pipeline 2012
Astra Seneca was a completely different
company we had
great sales great profit and virtually
no pipeline whatsoever this is the time
that Pascal Torio came into the company
and that the company changed leadership
so if we fast forward from that time
about five or six years
from
almost no pipeline whatsoever
some analysts claimed that we had the
best pipeline in the industry
questions remain about the dearth of
cash flow highlighted by the daiichi
deal the issue for Astra is that there's
only so much cash and as we know that is
one of the key questions around the
company let's go more into that though
so why is that a question well well
pharmaceutical companies are
historically great cash generators
there's two reasons people have
historically invested in pharmaceutical
companies one is the the fact that
they're driven by demographics and they
are a defensive sector normally and the
other one is that they throw off tons of
cash so where the cash flow becomes a
bit thinner that becomes a question and
of course there's not much you can do
when three say roughly five billion
dollar products at the same time are
going off patent and products at the end
of their lives are very profitable
because they don't need much detailing
how do you you know how do you replace
that that's that's a pretty difficult
thing to do that said fazelli says
astrazeneca's latest results did
indicate that cash flow is going to
improve on the back of growth and high
margin products
as far as sorio is concerned it's not
his biggest worry
witness a decision announced in June to
invest 630 million dollars over the next
five years in the South Korean Health
Care sector or a 220 million dollar
commitment to Vietnam's Health sector
unveiled in May the bigger risk for us
is to become complacent actually you
know it's interesting we didn't have
anything
we then wear a potentially Acquired and
there was an enormous burning platform
for all of us to do our best and work
hard and move fast and as you become
successful you can become slower and
more complacent so that's the one thing
really we I don't want to see happen
[Music]
it was a Triumph of social media
marketing
feel good exuberance mob in New York's
iconic Grand Central Station
at the dawn of the Instagram age
today is a media in general it's not
anymore newspaper Magazine TV radio
today's media means you have to attract
for a track
a community you have you really have you
have to talk with them every day
[Music]
when montclair's chief executive Raymer
rafini staged his New York spectacular
since cyclists into Milan's velodrome or
took over the Lincoln Center
he'd already stepped outside the
traditional boundaries of the catwalk
into the realm of the theater Welcome to
The Winter Palace tapping into the
social media Zeitgeist that had helped
Propel an almost bankrupt French ski
wear company into the upper echelons of
global fashion
[Music]
now he's taking a new risk
in 2018 rafini announced he was going to
ditch the business model that had
supported the turnaround of the failing
company he'd bought in 2003 when he
propelled it from a mid-ranking ski gear
maker to a business among the most
profitable listed luxury companies in
the world
but ruffini has refused to rest on his
laurels in an effort to prepare the
company for the next stage of expansion
and turbocharged sales he announced a
new way of doing business
instead of spring summer winter fall
men's and women's he now has a
collection every month with eight
different designers he dubbed it genius
for me it's an incredible instrument of
communication
because he could have something to talk
about to the market every month
with famous designers nice images of
products very Innovative products
strange products so it's incredible
reach of content this approach this
collection allows them to with great
frequency
be sharing something new be bringing
different influencers targeting
different sub segments of their of their
consumer base and it gives them a lot to
talk about on social media it's probably
the most valuable asset that they have
on social media today they really are
working on what Montclair will be in
five years time
so I think that this approach long-term
approach
could be a guarantee that they could
still have room to to grow David Tweed
what I wanted to ask first is what is
the essence of Genius
so you're really content content on
content the people they need content
they need the people need ideas then at
the end of the day they need also
product to go into the stores but you
know our strategy is based to attract
people every month in the stores but not
only to sell a jacket but it's you know
also to participate to our to our let's
call Festival you know and again our our
strategy is based on all generation
means every month we we like it we want
to talk with different Generations
the strategies seem to work the year of
the launch sales Rose by a fifth the
fastest Pace in three years and the
share price has staged a recovery after
its steady Ascent stalled briefly at the
end of last year the way that it works
is that they're using the base of their
history but allowing creativity
individual to individually to those
collaborators that reaches a much
younger audience speed of audience is
very much a cachet on digital and
e-commerce and creates a buzz around
other products that are available under
the Montclair brand like this puffer
jacket for dogs a snip at 425 dollars
in the fourth quarter of 2018 Montclair
was the biggest gainer in ranking of
luxury searches compiled by list a
global fashion search platform
genius diffusion lines drop monthly and
were responsible for the Brand's biggest
spikes in both social engagement and
search volume genius is about how do I
give something for my consumers to talk
about on a regular basis right one of
the challenges of traditional luxury is
there is an inherent conservatism in
some ways right I need to stand for
something consistent I can't be
refreshing all the time yet that makes
it difficult in a social media world
what do I talk about every week and if
I'm not talking to my consumers every
week they're not listening so this these
collaborations the the frequent launches
allow them to have something to talk
about you know represent less than 10 of
their sales a day but I would expect
half of what's discussed on social media
if you can measure it another crucial
thing in the fashion industry today is
that you have something that is limited
today everybody wants in the market
something that is limited you know you
collect watches you collect shoes you
collect whatever so it's a trend for me
it's very important for the genius also
that the fact that every month you have
a collection you have a designer and
that's it then you cannot buy anymore
in 2003 ruffini bought Montclair a 50
year old French Sports Fair company on
the brink of insolvency montclair's
sales were less than 50 million euros at
the time last year turnover was 1.4
billion I was very familiar with the
brand but because in Italy in the 70s
was very very popular
and I bought my first monkey that was
like 14 15 years old I was living out of
my own town is Cuomo and my house was a
little bit out of Como like six seven
kilometers and every morning I use my
motorcycle to go to the school when I
was 14 15 at that time was much more
cold than today
and I always use this jacket very bright
very shiny
Montclair is named after monastia de
Claremore an Alpine town in France
founded in 1952 it made tense and
quilted sleeping bags and its workers
wore quilted coats to keep warm
Mountaineer Lionel Terry saw them and
suggested Montclair outfit his 1954
expedition to K2 considered the world's
most dangerous mountain to climb Akili
compagnani and Lino lacidali were the
first to successfully reach its Summit
in 1954. kitted out in Montclair
the brand became a favorite among the
Jet Set Bridget Bardot
Jackie Kennedy
the Empress of Iran
but when rafini bought it the company
was on the skids buffeted from
competition from the likes of Prada and
the North Face that time was a trendy
brand but it was mainly a ski wear brand
so you had basic colors I remember you
had the yellow red blue but nothing to
compare with today of course yes after a
while I think in the the end of the 80s
beginning in 90s they lost their way it
was still I think a French brand at that
time and then Mr rufini came over the
brand and decided to to buy it try
looking for something real with the
strong roots and after six seven months
looking for the market I realized
Montclair was
could possible available and after one
year talking I bought the brand and this
was a fantastic fantastic example how to
redesign the company we keep to keep the
roots as as close as you can and then
you talk about the DNA a lot right yeah
a lot because I think you have to
respect especially when you have a brand
they have a very strong DNA wired
through this on the garbage or whatever
I think it's very important to keep the
DNA to try to be more than to be try to
improve everything but the DNA is very
very important
[Music]
ruffini decided to move the company here
to Milan Italy's fashion Capital people
tell me though that that you are
considered to be a master in brand
Rejuvenation okay so what did you do
when you first went into Montclair in
2003 and you looked at the range and
thought okay this is how we're going to
take this brand forward how did you do
it what were the the nuts and bolts of
that
honestly nothing's special come on
honestly I went there I started working
really on the small things you know I
started working on first in the product
in the quality to redesign the ideas
because at the end of the day you you
need you need a big brand but you need
also a contemporary product
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the global puffer jacket this
was Rhema ruffini's big idea to take a
piece of outerwear that was normally
only used on the slopes when you're
skiing or in Alpine Expeditions and turn
it into a luxury item that people would
like to wear in town
you developed this idea of the global
down jacket yes because for me it was
important not only to remain on this
kind of store so not only used for
hiking or climbing and also I think it
was a big potential to use this product
also walking to the street you know
that's why I start working on quality on
weight on performance on all these kind
of things I read one you were looking at
people in an air in an airline or in in
an airplane that just arrived from New
York
yes because uh since when I bought the
company I bought one jacket I use as
soon I realized it was impossible to use
because one day you go New York is cold
maybe it's okay with your jacket but
then you fly you fly to Tokyo is 22
degrees you don't know where you put the
jack is huge right you don't have enough
space on the bag to put the jacket and I
say lightness is very important you know
softness and everything on that I really
work on technology I really work on
weight I really work on this kind of
thing and then as I start walking around
the water to understand what is the
potential of this brand and understand
which kind of kind of people they can
use they can use in the city or nothing
only in the mountain and then
after one year I really tried to move
the brand from the as I say Sport Goods
stores into more luxury environment
once you got
the prop ruffini executed the next part
of his plan the gam Rouge line for women
the first time skiwa had been presented
as fashion followed by Gambler for men
[Music]
with each show becoming more of an event
an Autumn forest for the girls
strobing striptease for the boys
to say nothing of the 2009 Grand Central
Station flash mob an event almost
perfectly timed with Instagram becoming
a thing then came the stores
this is the Via Monte napoleoni it is
without doubt the most prestigious
luxury fashion Street in all of Italy
Prada Ferragamo Armani so it makes
absolute sense that when Montclair
decides to expand and open a flagship
store in Milan
it chooses this location yes after two
three years you know late 2008 I decided
to open my first store I said where I
opened the stores you know it could be
you know champions
We decided to go straight to to the most
Luxury Street in Europe basically one of
the most relaxing Street in Europe we
opened in small stores in
inora honestly we feel
since when we opened the doors that the
brand was a good good receipts from this
kind of customer you know we have line
outside every day basically and managing
your own distribution though that's
something that's also key isn't it
I think in the beginning this was
another turning point I decided to busy
cancel all distribution agent license
really I think my dream was really to
control 100 my since the day one my
everything and we can sell all the
partner because you know it's quite
conflict of interest I want to build up
a brand that they won't sell sell and
sell
and I start my retail business my alone
I open my store directly my not only in
Paris open my story all around the world
from China Japan United States I mean it
was much more difficult but I the good
thing I control the process I think
control everything have this fast
feedback from the market understand
what's going on especially at the
beginning when we have like three four
five stores I call them every night you
don't understand what's going on
now is little bit more difficult but
with data you can have the same feedback
there was a real concerted effort to
open up retail you also saw a move away
from the wholesale right so into that
retail transition so this was the period
I would say of real expansion becoming a
global brand right and and really
putting down starting to put down a lot
of flags here in Asia
the retail strategy here retail sales
the pale orange bars easily outpace
wholesale the bright orange bars still
ahead how Rima rafini developed his
China strategy this is montclair's Hong
Kong flagship store it's one of about
half a dozen outlets in the city and it
is vast we're looking at 500 square
meters of retail space it was the
biggest Outlet in all of Asia until the
beginning of the year when a bigger
store opened in Singapore ruffini thinks
that China is where the growth and
luxury is going to be Montclair is just
getting started
[Music]
nearly a decade after buying the company
ruffini decided it was time to take
Montclair public a second attempt after
the first was foiled by the market
upheaval surrounding the Greek crisis
it was a way for rafini to arrange an
exit for his private Equity investor
without having to turn to new private
Equity funding since the beginning of
private equity in my company they helped
me to buy the company at the beginning
was mitted and catalyzed that is an
American priority who came to the to the
company and after that as you know they
need an exit basically and Caroline late
2009 2010 to me we need to exit at least
a part
I don't want to start again to make you
know raising the or another private
tickets okay let's try to go public
in the end Carlisle sold its 45 stake to
French private Equity company or azeo in
the winter of 2013 Montclair has its
initial public offering it turns out to
be the most successful in Europe that
year the shares rise 41 on the first day
of trading valuing the company at 3.6
billion Euro about 5 billion US Dollars
Raymer rafini becomes one billion
dollars richer
you're a Zeo hung onto its stake for
eight years selling the last five
percent in March
over the years its investment generated
a return of 1.4 billion euros and an
internal rate of return of 43 percent
[Music]
the IPO funds helped back the expansion
into China that started in 2011. a
market that partly inspired rafini to
launch genius
[Music]
says the key is first of all to
establish the brand
and the stores will follow I think the
future of luxury is for sure China I
think we are still very small in China
three four years ago I decided that in
China it was better to sell brand brand
perception and sell jacket we're not
open to many stores I think we have huge
possibility to increase our size of the
store increased number of doors at the
moment we got less than I think 30
stores so right now for you China is
about selling brand perception it's like
you're preparing the market I think it's
very important because fortunately 10
years channel will be the biggest Market
I don't know if in 10 years I will be
there you know it means the most
important things to remain strong in
China is to build up a very strong brand
for sure the Mac will be the biggest
[Music]
it it's a prediction shared by others in
the industry I think it's important to
recognize the secular trend of the
growing affluent in China so there is a
lot of news and volatility that we read
about the trade War right we if we were
sitting here in 2013 we would have been
talking about anti-corruption which
actually took a big gifting portion of
the luxury goods Market away right and
then all of a sudden there was a lot of
naysayers on the China luxury Market but
actually what was still happening is
still happening today is a very
consistent growth of the Chinese
affluent and that's why we predict there
will be up to 40 percent of the global
luxury Market by 2023 because it's a
secular growth of this segment so
there'll be some ups and downs but the
the overall trend is still there 40 from
what uh it's about 32 today
[Music]
the Chinese market is vast but not
necessarily easy like when Dolce and
Gabbana released a marketing video
depicting a Chinese Beauty trying to eat
pizza with chopsticks it didn't help the
Brand's reputation when one of the
founders let fly with an attack on
China's netizens
the boycott ensued
that's an issue when Chinese Shoppers
are estimated to account for at least a
third of luxury sales and two-thirds of
the industry's growth how do you go
about avoiding making cultural errors in
a market which is let's face it it's a
foreign market
I think the CB4 since the first day we
decided to go directly in every Market a
team is very important team you build
there is very important because I only
stay I always say to to the guys who
have to be domestic because this is very
important because the culture of the
language everything is totally different
I cannot talk the same language in
Japanese or in Beijing even if it is one
hour flight the country is so different
that you need something local to help
you but at the same time you have to be
domestic my for sure you need a global
vision because otherwise you become a
domestic company means it's the mix you
know and the team you have in the region
is very very important it's a fine line
to balance you know I think if you've
seen recent scandals Dolce Gabbana it's
important to have a sensitivity to
understand who your consumers are have
it in in place some of the governance
and guard rails to help contain the
conversation to be appropriate and
inspiring for for who those consumers
but if you do make a mistake then how do
you react to it I'm sorry right and
sometimes I mean I think there's you
know there are probably many approaches
to this being upfront and and
straightforward and not letting you know
the the thing fester for a long time you
know was probably one of the better ways
to execute right in the face of a of a
significant error or mistake
[Music]
despite montclair's success questions do
remain about whether it's a risk to base
an entire business on one product a
puffer jacket we see huge growth
potential in the puffer Jack of its
Heritage its history its base its
foundation
there isn't a huge amount of competition
out there so we would say that there's
definitely longevity there and even
around the new
design implementations and one of
collaborations that they have going on
the puffer jacket provides the base so
the answer would be no we see long-term
growth Prospect for the puffy jacket
genius was as much a device to create a
conversation with customers as it was to
shake up his own company after 10 years
in my feeling was everybody sleep a
little bit in the company
and I think we have to we say we have to
change something we have to attract
different customers we have to we
thought everyone was a bit asleep in the
company yes because after 10 years also
myself yeah also myself because the
business was always the same you have
two fashion show here you know spring
summer walking winter and then the upper
spring summer autumn in the spring
summer to win I think this this war they
need much more energy
and that's why we decide to move our
ideas from seasonal business into
monthly business
facing his business isn't an
over-reliance on a single product or the
vagaries of a Faraway Market
it's at home
the bigger risk I think is us the team I
think as I say before the world changed
very fast
if you if you if we not follow the world
we're gonna lose
foreign
[Music]
maker Carlsberg put its reputation on
the line when it launched an advertising
campaign that admitted its beer in
Britain wasn't what it was supposed to
be
it was an admission that could only come
as a result of a profound change in the
culture of the company brought about by
this man case to Heart a Dutchman with a
reputation for forging Unity from
division
well when I came in this business
um I started to talk with many people I
think I had 200 interviews and everybody
more or less had the same this is a
siled company when Caster hard arrived
at Carlsberg in 2015 he found a company
demoralized by a badly timed investment
in the Russian Market that had forced it
to stand on the sidelines of a wave of
Brewing industry consolidation what is
special about the Carlsberg turnaround
is really how case to heart has
triggered the turnaround by returning
the company to its original purpose that
the founder set out and really engaging
the workforce when I think back to 2015
I suppose what for me was very different
about Carlsberg versus today was I don't
think we had any real Clarity on the way
forward we looked at our competitors we
looked at the industry consolidation
that was happening and was happening
pretty fast at that time and there was a
lot of concern about the future now what
is the Carlsberg 1883 when I met Kester
heart I wanted to ask how do you deal
with all these issues at once we put
that together in a strategy which is
called cell 22. so we have the a seven
year program if you like the start of a
journey
on the other hand we realized ourselves
together as our top people that we
didn't have the money to do the journey
so we said okay let's do two things we
create the future for ourselves and
that's then called cell 32 but we front
our own Journey
reluctant to our shareholders for funds
to hard adopted to cut costs and invest
the Savings in premium brand strategy
the plan addressed the concerns that had
prompted the Carlsberg Foundation which
has controlled the Brewer since 1876 to
seek out a new chief executive in the
first place
the Brewers debt had been mounting
turnover and profit was down
stemming from the decision in 2008 to
take full control of baltica Russia's
leading beer brand a move that turned
spectacularly sour because after that
deal Russia accounted for a third of
carlsberg's revenues
just as a wired alcoholism epidemic
prompted the government to crack down on
sales and increase taxes on beer by 200
percent
[Music]
in 2014 another blow International
sanctions after Russia's incursion into
Ukraine undermined its economy
carlsberg's Eastern European sales
slumped it meant that as the margins
declined and as the overall
profitability declined they were
unable to react in that market and then
it removed any Firepower for them to
participate in significant m e in other
markets or even to support other markets
with with the kind of marketing spend
that would be required versus very
strong and very deep pocketed
competitors
that wave of mergers and Acquisitions
had led to the creation of companies
like Anheuser-Busch inbev or ABI a
brewing Behemoth nine times carlsberg's
size
[Music]
the first leg of the turnaround is
called funding the journey the idea was
to cut costs to free up cash to invest
in the growth leg of the turnaround
dubsale 22
breweries were closed in Russia and
China to get rid of excess capacity
Supply chains revamped to strip out
costs
the results can be seen in a net debt to
earnings chart it peaks in 2008 the
purchase of the Russian Brewery it drops
onto Hearts 2015 appointment as his cost
savings are used to pay off debt and his
investments in Brands improve earnings
so although basically taking the cost
out of the business so that you could
then release cash to invest in the core
business in the core Brands uh also
reduce your debt from it was around
about three times that that when you
came in so that you could reduce that
debt and actually release cash to doing
m a
the funding the journey program it's not
something that was finite Carlsberg is
continually striving to cut costs and
improve efficiencies which is why this
machine here has just had its head
redesigned so it can pick up not just
one but two of carlsberg's newest
products the draft master
and this is a draft Master it's a new
type of lightweight keg
but it's still pretty heavy what's
really interesting is that all of the
production of this type of keg is done
in this plant instead of all around
Europe they bring the beer in it turns
out it's much cheaper and it's still
part of funding the journey
leg of the turnaround sale 22 is
a Five-Year Plan designed to generate
sales growth through investment in
premium Brands as well as specialty and
no alcohol beers
the impact can be seen here last year
the value of sales increased 6.5 percent
while beer volumes climbed just under
five percent Carlsberg is selling more
expensive beer
the strategy can be seen directly in the
real and projected gains in earnings per
share and a share price near record
levels Carlsberg has taken out a lot of
cost through the funding the journey
program and then they've used that money
to invest into growth into really moving
the company up up Market again and
really get back to a winning streak
[Music]
cognizant that Carlsberg needed to
invest and loathe to ask shareholders to
forego dividends case to Heart came up
with a two-pronged turnaround strategy
but he had to get Senior Management on
board he bought and built Clarity around
the strategy around how he saw us
growing and how he saw us funding that
growth in a way that was stretching but
everyone felt was realistic I think the
other part of that was the way that he
did that
basically we said look we have an issue
here
we have this satisfies shareholders we
look at our feedback of our people they
are not satisfied our supervisory board
is not certified our customers have the
feel that we don't come with the right
rules and Innovation and so on forth so
really we have an issue
um and um I'm not going to solve that
issue for you we are going to solve the
tissue and that means that we're going
to co-create the Future that's been
pretty shocking pretty shocking for a
lot of those people in the room how many
of those top 60 then in 2015 are still
in the top 60. yeah I raise that
question uh of course I knew who were
new but um we were in December 2018 in
Belgium in greenberger where one of our
Visa is coming from and
um there were 22
hands up at the moment that I asked who
was with us at the other third about a
third so that's a pretty telling
statistic you've had a pretty big
turnover at the top in the management
now they haven't necessarily left
Carlsberg but uh I think most of them
did right we started really from the top
so we really started with the executive
committee and at the moment you start to
bring in new people in your executive
committee they start as well to work
with people they really feel can do the
work for the future and and change
people
foreign
building because it's very special it's
built around an old Silo in the middle
part there are no windows so that
becomes a sort of void but it's more
than a symbolic void it's a physical
void case to heart's office when he
became cos on the top floor and he used
to say to his staff I could die up here
and no one would find me for three days
because no one's walking past so what
he's done is he's moved his office from
the top floor down to the second floor
that means he's in the thick of it he's
collaborating he's communicating to
heart is taking his move from the top
floor to the second floor one big step
further a completely new headquarters it
will be over there in the q1 2020 but
then we will be in a totally new office
where
everybody has open Office there's only
four floors in total and the consequence
of that is that we will all mingle
together and by that I think there will
be much more energy in the business or
even more energy in the business people
come in and see that it's a contemporary
business that's not what the kind of
field you have at the moment you step in
now
one of the other concerns at the
Carlsberg Foundation was that the
company had veered from the vision laid
out by the founder J.C Jacobson in the
19th century that profits of the company
would be channeled to support art
science and culture
[Music]
The Little Mermaid is the number one
tourist attraction in Copenhagen
commissioned by Carlsberg Carl Jacobson
the son of the founder fell in love with
the story by Hans Christian Anderson
about a mermaid who gave up everything
in order to be able to swim to the
surface and be with her beloved but then
she died but the link with Carlsberg
goes on because Carlsberg Foundation is
still funding the Arts here in Denmark
Carl Jacobson founded the glypto ticket
a museum devoted to sculpture in
downtown Copenhagen that was packed the
day I visited
and it was this contribution to society
the foundation's purpose that Fleming
besenbacker wanted to nurture when he
was looking for a new chief executive
what was it about keys to heart that
made you think that he was going to be a
fit for Carlsberg and also the
objectives of the foundation why did I
take him well I think first of all in
case I've done a fantastic turnaround in
the first time computer and I could see
her turn around voice also needed in
Carlsberg between 2009 and 2015 Tejada
presided over the successful integration
of two Dutch Dairy cooperatives which
before the merger had considered
themselves to be virtual enemies but
also from talking to him he specifically
said to me if I take this job I do not
take it only if this was an ordinary job
just to create value for shareholders
I've been used to work for farmers in
the Netherlands
if I take this job I would like to work
for scientists in Denmark and with the
foundation and so forth here also was
willing to focus on the purpose also
willing to focus on sustainability one
of the things about Carlsberg that I've
been hearing a lot about is
purpose-driven leadership now can you
explain what is that about what is it
well basically it comes back to why why
would you come to the office what is
basically you think that you and your
colleagues can contribute not only to
the business but maybe a broader
perspective as well so it comes and
that's where we started what is the the
what the how and the why and many
companies start with the Y but we were
finding that a bit difficult to find the
the why at the beginning had it been
lost the why at Carlsberg we think so
and it took me personally almost nine
months to 12 months to really find the
why what about your own journey in
leadership
well I think the biggest decision in my
life was to move out of HR the point
that really made me think was having an
uh an exit talk with a person that
needed to be fired and was as old as my
father
and the decision was not taken by myself
so I I was if you like literally almost
executed and I thought this is not how I
would like to to spend my life to
execute things that other people have
have decided
and then I started to feel like how will
I come to well maybe not CEO of a
company but in leadership roles in the
universe that was very much via
marketing so I moved from HR to
marketing and then moved the letter to
General management one of the things
I've heard you describing your
management team is is like a football
yeah team uh and not everyone's a
striker it is head office against the
countries it's marketing against sale
it's Finance again the rest the rest of
the world so it felt a bit like this is
a company let's say that we have 30
countries that we are playing on 30
different soccer fields and one of the
first pictures I showed to people so
well we are now all playing in different
teams on different soccer fields we are
now in in the future one team and that
means that we have the guys in the the
in the countries they are the strikers
they need to score the goal so it means
as well that they need to know
everything about the consumer and the
customer in their country then we have a
few midfielders supply chain group
commercial these are the people that
need to make the plans passing the ball
if you like or the plans at the right
moment with the right specs that
swansfort but they are not scoring the
goals I never see people in the defense
like HR and finance and legal and they
need to make sure that we don't make big
mistakes or develop our people and so
forth
coming up more from case to heart and
the UK advertising campaign and what it
tells you about the new Carlsberg so why
don't we have a beer
yeah let's do that
[Music]
when kaster heart joins Carlsberg he
launched a dual recovery plan savings
and growth
there was also cultural change and
that's where carlsberg's purpose
statement comes in I decided to talk
about that we Brew for better today and
basically we talked about the the
quality and the Brews and basically that
we needed to perform better but as well
about the future we we said a certain
moment we grew for a better today and
tomorrow
[Music]
foreign
showed he was prepared to walk the walk
in one of carlsberg's key 18 Western
European markets
in Britain Carlsberg was traditionally
made with a 3.8 alcohol content lower
than elsewhere where the taste was
richer and as more craft beers came into
the UK Market tastes evolved leaving
carlsberg's Brew behind
Elena golfman worked on the strategy for
carlsberg's advertising agency in London
we realized that
the market was starting to shift and
people's
tastes and priorities and palettes were
changing people were demanding better
quality beer so it wasn't as much about
consuming loads and loads of it it was
about consuming beer that you thought
was of good quality and we realized that
Carlsberg had started to suffer from a
perception issue first and foremost
like drinking the bath water your nan
died in
Carlsberg announced it had changed its
beer and introduced new Carlsberg in the
British Market it was a brave campaign
because you have to admit your mistakes
and in the UK Market anyway the the
Carlsberg brand was probably thought of
as a mainstream brand rather than
premium and it's premium everywhere else
in Europe and that is the way they want
to take the beer and the beer suffered
Danish Superstar mads Mickelson told the
UK audience that we dance don't cry in
for our beer
we focus on brewing a better one brewing
for a better today that means that we're
never satisfied with what we have and
that's I think what we recognized in the
UK maybe the consume was earlier than we
did because we saw our market share
declining and that means that the
customer and the consumers don't like
your brand anymore so we digged into
that to that and we looked at the the
Brews and we we improved if you look at
the recent advert in the UK where they
they said Carlsberg you know probably
not the best the best beer almost
um being self-deprecating regarding what
had been a platform of their their
advertising for for years then that that
really indicates a flexible mindset
towards towards Brands and a recognition
that you need portfolios that satisfy
the needs of local consumers in in
individual markets
[Music]
to heart's efforts to return to the
scientific underpinnings of the founder
are felt here in the Carlsberg research
laboratory
which over the years has delivered
breakthroughs such as the first
cultivation of pure yeast and the
invention of the pH scale
and so these are all the Brews well this
I actually do when people have been
employed with Carlsberg or here in the
Carlsberg laboratory for more than 25
years then you get your own bottle of
beer and look here's mine oh it's a big
one looks like yeah and there was a
beautiful you know wheat passion fruit
lager oh very nice tell me more about
what's happened since uh since we've
seen case to Heart come to uh to
Carlsberg because I believe there's
there's been more integration I think
there has been a lot of integration and
there has been a lot more of agility but
also I would say that you know hear from
a research point of view we have been
very much integrated now into the whole
business and especially into all the
Strategic priorities for sale 22 really
how so well I think you know we have a
lot of focus now on really supporting
the Strategic areas like Core Beer
making a difference in that craft and
Specialty non-alcoholic beer and here at
the research laboratory can really
support a lot with completely new types
of yeast strains producing normal
alcohol and there are also other types
of yeast strain that can give a consumer
benefit better taste experience Aromas
and so on and that plays into sales 22
because it's got the focus on corbia but
also new products yes it does very much
so again I would say we have today very
very much on the agenda in you know the
whole commercial agenda and we are today
very much in front also you know when we
have commercial meetings and when we
have visitors and so on so again I think
that's also the history of the
laboratory cosberg has quite a unique
history when it comes to research and
Science and it's basically also having
the more fundamental science which was
founded here in the laboratory
one of carlsberg's key areas for growth
is Asia the driver of its most recent
Revenue gains particularly where we see
a lot of growth coming from is in
premiumization so driving into more
premium categories more premium Brands
and that's really been a fantastic
driver for us in China for instance
where we have a good Geographic
footprint and some very strong positions
in some specific markets but we're
really looking to expand Beyond those
and to launch into new cities and to
particularly launch with the more
premium brands in the portfolio
since 2014 carlsberg's increased its
share of the premium Market in China to
14 from 9 percent
while Abi's share has dropped to 43
percent
[Music]
China helped drive a 9.5 increase in
carlsberg's 2019 first quarter beverage
sales in Asia which now accounts for a
third of carlsberg's Total Beverage
sales still ABI represents a threat
alongside Heineken which last year
struck a partnership deal with China's
biggest Brewer
you know China as I say Carlsberg have
done a very good job there but you would
imagine that in the areas of and
channels in China where Carlsberg have
been doing well there will be
competitive pressures coming in
Carlsberg is well aware of the
competitive challenges it faces but even
so to hear it from the people I talked
to at Carlsberg during my visit there
case to Heart seems to have succeeded in
injecting a new sense of yes I'll use
his word purpose into the company the
question is how to keep the momentum
going by renewing ourselves if you like
setting the sales tweaking it making
sure that we keep our speed having three
times a year the top 60 being
self-critical or are we really
delivering maybe sometimes being a bit
paranoid as well about whether the wind
is coming from Another Side than we
expected whether the waves are a bit
higher than the the forecasted these
kind of things and the top team is
really very good at it what advice would
you give to another chief executive who
was looking at a company that also needs
to be turned around
uh plan for the worst and downtown
promise
[Music]